[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy whose videos
he'd have to be mad smikkelson to skip
and this video while breaking down
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore it's difficult to discuss
this movie without at least
acknowledging the recasting of johnny
depp all the recent stuff with ezra
miller and of course jk rowling the
three of which have been trending on
twitter almost every day for the past
couple of weeks i have my own opinions
on all the situations but i'm just gonna
keep them out of this video and focus on
the film itself otherwise we'll be here
all day discussing the ins and outs of
what's been going on behind the scenes
hope you appreciate that and the film
very much revolves around a creature
called the chillin that's able to look
into someone's soul and see whether
they've been naughty or nice think of
the sorting hat but without the slick
voice of leslie phillips this is a
highly sought after creature because it
somewhat has the ability of precognition
and it's able to look into someone's
soul and see their darkest desires god
amit you've seen this somewhere before
and because of its gifts it's used to
decide who will become the supreme head
of the international confederation of
wizards attaining this would make one
the king of the world and grindelwald
seeks after these beasts so that he can
manipulate their abilities that's the
basic plot of the film and earlier in
the movie we pick up with newt who's
attempting to track one down he comes
across one in the process of giving
birth which is when creedence bear but
sorry barebone arrives with
grindelwald's acolytes they've been
chilling like a villain and end up
killing the chilean and creedence takes
the newborn to grindelwald who ends its
life and puts a spell on its corpse
however it turns out that the chilean
gave birth the twins and you takes the
other now i know ezra is non-binary and
goes by they and them but for the
character of credence i'll be using he
and him just as he's described as being
a male disclaimer over now caught in the
middle of this is queenie who i totally
forgot defected until this week when i
rewatched the first two films was always
a bit of a weird character term for me
that kinda came out of the blue
especially as she'd heard nothing other
than how bad grindelwald was for two
whole movies she can read people's
thoughts and wouldn't know that
grindelwald wald was a bad guy but his
speech about allowing magic people to
live without restrictions could have
added to her motivation she of course
wanted to be with jacob which would be
frowned upon because he's a muggle and
he kind of brings her back from the
brink now through her we see all the bad
that grindelwald does and on the
opposite side of this we have dumbledore
calling on newt his brother and some
others to stop the villain because he's
unable to from the first scene the movie
makes it crystal clear that they're in
love and due to the pack that they made
they can't haunt the other thus they
very much have to use the characters as
pawns and everyone in the movie is
pulled into their rivalry which asks
whether dumbledore cares about people or
if he just sees them as a means to an
end now come the end of the movie they
are able to fight because the blood out
breaks how this happens isn't spelled
out exactly but it's likely because
dumbledore goes to protect credence
whilst grindelwald tries to kill him
potentially when both carry out this
action it negates the other which breaks
the oath or it could just be lazy
writing now grindelwald is here which
basically means that he can look into
the future and thus the plans that
dumbledore's forces make have to be
confusing the plot kind of jumps all
over the place a bit and it's steeped in
politics even though they have the
stupidest way to decide a leader ever
bowing to public pressure german
minister for magic anton vogel ends up
allowing grendel wall to run and the
villain takes the possessed body of the
chill into the election typically these
beasts bow before someone in order to
show that they are worthy and being
under his control it makes it look like
he's who should be put in charge of
everything however the homie newt and
his team sneak the second chilling in
and using several suitcases that all
look the same they not only confused
grindelwald but managed to get their guy
close to the election creedence points
out that the one that's team grindelwald
is dead and the living one drops in in
front of dumbledore however he doesn't
want to lead and it's often said that
the best leader you can have is someone
who doesn't want to do it it's kind of
weird seeing a movie that's basically
about election fraud and i was expecting
credence to pop in and say stop the
steal lots of social commentary and thus
the leadership position falls to santos
from this point on grindelwald takes
himself on credence who of course caused
his mission to fail now credence is a
dumbledore and we learn that he's
actually the son of abel fourth abel
fourth feels extremely guilty over what
happened with his son and he
communicates to him through mirrors at
several points in the movie sadly
credence is dying and we discovered that
because he's an obscurial that he's
living on borrowed time and obscurius is
a parasite that attaches itself to a
young wizard a witch that has been told
they can't use their magic in an abusive
manner harry potter never got one for
reasons and most kids that are affected
by this end up dying quite young which
explains why grindelwald and co want to
free their people from the secrecy they
have to live in now we discover that
this parasite is actually killing
credence and we end the movie with him
being reunited with his father the pair
go off together to spend what little
time they have left with each other and
knowing what we know about the harry
potter movies credence or rather
aurelius doesn't live long enough to
meet harry due to the controversy around
ezra they might even kill a character
off screen and who knows what's going to
happen really the series was supposed to
be 5 films long but they do kind of wrap
up most of the arcs here so if they want
to end it early yeah then they easily
can now i kind of jumped ahead a bit
there and we should really be focusing
on grindelwald and dumbledore though the
blood earth between the pair is broken
in the end they decide to lower their
wands because deep down they still love
each other after hearing their
heartbeats both walk away from the fight
and grindelwald makes off however
dumbledore is told to not stop hunting
grindelwald though he does seem torn
between his duty and his heart now we
know from the expanded lore that both
grindelwald and dumbledore have a
legendary showdown in 1945 aka the end
of the second world war this film was
actually set in 1932 and therefore we're
gonna have to have some major time
differences between the next two movies
if that's to happen as the final
showdown we of course could set the next
film in 1939 aka the beginning of the
second world war and then have the final
one culminate at its closing jk rowling
has hinted that both the war and
grindelwald swan are very much linked
with one another and that they're meant
to be parallels the creative team behind
the film have said they'd love to go to
japan and with the country being a key
figure in the war you might end up
heading there so more politics can play
out now i really wonder if they're
setting up to finish in germany so that
just as the nazis fall grindelwald does
too as i said it's likely gonna
culminate in 1945 with not only the end
of the war but also the battle between
dumbledore and grindelwald now another
thing i think we need to talk about is
tina who was a series mainstay however
she's had a massively reduced role and
she only shows up briefly at the end of
the film though i promise to keep drama
out the video i feel like she has to be
touched upon because her statements
outside of the movie may have affected
her character's appearance now back in
2020 waterston shared an article about
how trans women posed no threat she
stated that because she's associated
with fantastic beasts that she had to
cite a position which many have seen as
her throwing shots jk rowling is a
screenwriter on the film and though
we'll probably never get it confirmed
there are theories that she reduced
catherine's role due to the statement
earlier on in the movie we learned that
she's the head of the aurora office at
makuza and though this would be the
perfect mission for her to show up to
she's completely absent bit weird and in
the end jacob gets to keep his wand as a
memento he marries queenie and newt
finally comes across tina outside they
have a bit of flirty back and forth
before they take tina and sides and you
can continue his practice for his best
man's speech he then spots dumbledore on
a bench he then thanks him for helping
him to stop grindelwald he says he'd do
it again if asked which likely sets up
what's gonna happen down the line
dumbledore ends up looking on this new
union of love thinking about the
bittersweet side of his one with
grindelwald that ends the film and in
some way culminates the journey though
we know we will likely get more now as
for my thoughts on the film i'm kind of
at a loss with this franchise harry
potter really set the bar this trilogy
has struggled to live up to and even
without the issues outside of the movie
i think it just falls flat for a number
of reasons mads just isn't as
intimidating as johnny depp is and
though he's a great actor he just kind
of always plays mads mikkelsen which
leaves it feeling a bit one note the
election storyline doesn't really hold
up to scrutiny and there's absolutely no
way that a democratic process would rely
on a magical horse to decide who gets to
rule over everything on top of this it's
now been announced by warner brothers
that the lines that hint to a gay
relationship between dumbledore and
grindelwald will be kept for china if
representation is so easy to remove then
it feels like they're just pandering and
i think that warner brothers are just
cowards for cutting something that they
made so integral to the plot innovations
that they give to the east it's clear
they don't really care about this stuff
and are only just doing it for the money
and to basically throw the west to bone
all around i just don't know what they
can do with this series and with it
being something that could be perceived
as a closing chapter i kind of think
they should maybe just end stuff here
move over to cursed child and then just
fill in what happened to end this series
in a flashback i feel really
disappointed after watching it and it
scores a five out of ten i'd of course
love to hear your thoughts i know those
people who enjoyed the movie so yeah i'm
happy to hear why you liked it and it
might make me appreciate it more so you
know if you enjoyed it then leave your
thoughts in the comments below we are in
competition right now and giving away
three copies of spider-man now a home on
the 15th of april and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the witness of the last
one on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown at moonlight which will be
linked on screen right now we go over
all the easter eggs in it give our
theories on what's going on with certain
characters so yeah definitely go check
it out right after this without the way
thanks for sticking through the video
i've been paul you mean the best i'll
see you next time take care peace